>> Trace: NEW COVID VARIANT IS
ANOTHER HURDLE IN A BUSY TIME IN
WASHINGTON, THE SENATE SET TO
RETURN TOMORROW, THE HOUSE ON
TUESDAY.
LAWMAKERS HAVE JUST A FEW DAYS
TO AVERT GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN AND
TWO WEEKS TO RAISE THE LIMIT ON
BORROWING OR DEFAULT FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN THE NATION’S
HISTORY. DEMOCRATS FACE A
DEADLOOIN FOR BUILD BACK BETTER
PLAN WITH NO REPUBLICAN SUPPORT,
THE NUMBER THREE REPUBLICAN IN
THE SENATE JOHN BARRASSO, WE
HAVE A LOT OF POLITICS TO TALK
ABOUT, YOU ARE GOING BACK TO
WORK TOMORROW, HOUSE COMES BACK
ON TUESDAY.
QUICKLY, A LOT OF BREAKING NEWSS
ON THE OMICRON VARIANT.
YOU’RE A MEDICAL DOCTOR, AS
WELL, GIVE US YOUR TAKE, ARE YOU
CONCERNED ABOUT THE NEW VARIANT
COMING POSSIBLY, MAYBE ALREADY
HERE IN THE UNITED STATES?
>> John: YOU KNOW, AS A DOCTOR,
I AM PRO-VACCINE AND
ANTI-MANDATE.
VACCINES WORK.
WE HAVE A NEW VARIANT, THERE
WILL CONTINUE TO BE NEW VARIANTS
IN THE FUTURE.
MEDICINES ARE BETTER NOW THAN
THEY HAVE BEEN.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT WAS WRONG
WITH HIS MANDATE, IT WAS A
MONUMENTAL OVERREACH AND IT’S
HARDENED PEOPLE AGAINST THE
VACCINE AND THE PRESIDENT
DIVIDED THE COUNTRY BECAUSE OF
THE MANDATE.
YOU HAVE GOVERNORS SAYING TWO
SHOTS ARE NOT ENOUGH, YOU HAVE
TO HAVE THREE.
THE THING THAT IS INTERESTING
ABOUT THIS, LAST GUEST TALKED
ABOUT INFLATION, 10 MILLION JOB
OPENINGS AND THE PRESIDENT WANTS
TO FIRE PEOPLE GOING TO WORK
EVERYDAY SINCE THE PANDEMIC
STARTED, PEOPLE WHO MAY NOT WANT
TO GET THE VACCINE.
POLICE OFFICERS, NURSES, BORDER
PATROL.
THAT IS ONE PART.
THE OTHER IS JOE BIDEN RAN FOR
OFFICE HIDING IN HIS BASEMENT
SAYING HE COULD PROTECT AMERICA
FROM COVID.
HE DIDN’T.
HE CAN’T.  MORE PEOPLE DIED
UNDER PRESIDENT BIDEN THAN DID
IN ALL OF 2020.
>> Trace: WE’LL TALK ABOUT THAT
WITH THE PANEL.
A LOT GOING ON THIS WEEK ON THE
HILL.
SENATOR, WHAT IS THE STATUS OF
THAT, WHERE IS IT GOING?
IS IT TIME TO INJECT TRILLIONS
BACK INTO THE ECONOMY?
>> John: NO, WE HAVE RECORD
INFLATION RIGHT NOW.
I VIEW THIS AS A BACK-BREAKING
BILL FOR THE COUNTRY WITH
EXPENSES, SPENDING, ADDING TO
DEBT, INFLATION, TAXES THAT ARE
GOING TO HIT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
FOR JOE BIDEN TO SAY SPEND MORE
ON TOP OF INFLATION, THIS IS
ALICE IN WONDERLAND, HE IS THE
MAD HADDER.
HE’S SAYING COST WILL BE ZERO,
ZERO, ZERO AND BUDGET ANALYSTS
SAY THERE WILL BE MUCH ADDED TO
THE DEBT.
TAXES WILL GO UP.
HE SAID, IF YOU MAKE OVER
$400,000 A YEAR, THAT IS NOT
WHAT EXPERTS SAY, THEY SAY ONE
OUT OF THREE WILL PAY MORE IN
TAXES.
ON ALL THE ISSUES AND INFLATION
ACROSS THE BOARD PEOPLE LOOK AT
PERSISTENT INFLATION.
THAT IS THE THING THAT WILL HURT
OUR ECONOMY THE MOST.
>> Trace: TALK ABOUT THE BUILD
BACK BETTER THING, THEY ARE
AGAINST RAISING DEBT LIMIT,
MITCH McCONNELL SAID IT WILL
ENABLE DEMOCRATIC SPENDING.
"WALL STREET JOURNAL" SAYS VOTE
TO RAISE DEBT LIMIT DOESN’T
AUTHORIZE NEW SPENDING, ALLOWS
TREASURY TO RAISE MONEY TO PAY
FOR EXPENSE THE GOVERNMENT
AUTHORIZED TO PAY FOR THINGS
AUTHORIZED AND IMPORTANT TO
POINT OUT IN YOUR STATE ALONE,
THIS IS PAYING FOR THINGS LIKE
30,000 PEOPLE GETTING SNAP
BENEFITS, FOOD BENEFITS, 33,000
ELIGIBLE FOR FREE OR REDUCED
SCHOOL LUNCHES, BENEFITS FROM
THIS TO YOUR STATE SENATOR.  WHY
ARE YOU AGAINST IT?
>> IN MY STATE, I WAS A MEMBER
OF THE STATE SENATE, OUR
INSTITUTION DEMANDS WE BALANCE
BUDGET EVERY YEAR AND LIVE
WITHIN OUR MEANS LIKE FAMILIES
NEED TO DO AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT OUGHT TO DO THE SAME
THING.
THIS IS ALL ABOUT DEMOCRATIC
SPENDING, 100% ON THEM.
GO YOU GET RID OF THE GIMMICKS
OF ACCOUNTING, THIS BILL THE
DEMOCRATS ARE PROPOSING IS $4
TRILLION IN ADDITIONAL SPENDING,
NOT A SINGLE REPUBLICAN WHO WILL
VOTE FOR THE BILL OR TO RAISE
THE DEBT CEILING, THIS IS ON
DEMOCRATS.
>> Trace: YOU ARE RANKING MEMBER
OF THE ENERGY COMMITTEE, I WANT
TO PUT THIS UP, FOOD, GAS,
ELECTRICITY PRICES.
WE’VE SEEN THIS AND TALKED WITH
DR. EL-ERIAN.
GAS IS UP, ELECTRICITY 6.5%, AND
WE’RE NOT AT THE COLDEST PART OF
THE WINTER, IT WILL GET BAD FOR
PEOPLE, EXPENSIVE.
THE PRESIDENT IS PUTTING 50
MILLION BARRELS OF OIL FROM THE
RESERVE BACK ON THE MARKET, MAY
HIT MID-DECEMBER.
ON THE OTHER HAND, THE PRESIDENT
IS MAKING IT MORE EXPENSIVE TO
DRILL ON FEDERAL LAND, HOW DO
YOU SQUARE THE TWO?
>> John: IT CANT BE SQUARED, THE
PRESIDENT IS NOT ABLE TO DO
THIS.
TODAY IS THE BUSIEST TRAVEL DAY
IN AMERICA, PEOPLE HIT THE ROAD,
GAS PRICES ARE HITTING THE ROOF.
DAY ONE IN THE WHITE HOUSE,
PRESIDENT DREW A TARGET ON THE
BACK OF AMERICAN ENERGY AND
PULLED THE TRIGGER.
WITH PETROLEUM RESERVE, PUTTING
A BANDAID ON THE BULLET HOLE.
THE RESERVE IS THERE FOR
EMERGENCIES, NATIONAL
EMERGENCIES, WAR, NOT TO COVER
OVER BAD POLICIES.
THE AMOUNT HE’S RELEASING IS
EQUAL TO WHAT WE USE IN JUST
2-1/2 DAYS.
AND TODAY, IN AMERICA, WE’RE
USING MORE OIL FROM RUSSIA, FROM
VLADAMIR PUTIN’S RUSSIA THAN
FROM ALASKA.
THIS IS A JACKPOT FOR VLADAMIR
PUTIN.
WE HAVE THIS OIL IN THE GROUND,
THE PRESIDENT AND ENVIRONMENTAL
MOVEMENT WILL NOT LET US USE
AMERICAN OIL, SO PRESIDENT BIDEN
GOING HAT IN HAND TO OPEC AND
RUSSIA SAYING, PLEASE PRODUCE
MORE OIL SO WE CAN BUY FROM YOU.
THIS IS A DISASTER, MAJOR POLICY
MISTAKE, WE NEED TO BE USING
AMERICAN ENERGY.
>> Trace: YOU GET TO WORK ON
CAPITOL HILL THIS WEEK, SIR,
WHAT IS REMEDY FROM THE
REPUBLICANS?
WHAT IS REMEDY?
IF THE PRESIDENT LEADS HERE, IF
HIS MOVES ARE NOT THE ELIXIR,
WHAT DO WE DO TO GET ENERGY AND
GAS PRICES DOWN AND STABILIZE
BEFORE WE MOVE INTO WINTER?
>> John: YES.
WE USE AMERICAN ENERGY, WE STOP
THE BANS THIS ADMINISTRATION HAS
ON ENERGY, SENATOR MANCHIN,
RANKING MEMBER, CHAIRMAN OF THE
ENERGY COMMITTEE SAID LET’S GET
KEYSTONE PIPELINE GOING.
WE HAVE RESOURCES HERE, WE ARE
MUCH STRONGER AS A NATION, IF
WE’RE SELLING ENERGY TO OUR
FRNDS THAN IF WE HAVE TO BUY IT
FROM OUR ENEMIES.
I JUST GOT BACK FROM THE PERSIAN
GULF, SPEND THANKSGIVING THERE
WITH WYOMING TROOPS AND TALKING
TO MILITARY LEADERS, AFTER WHAT
HAPPENED IN AFGHANISTAN, OUR
ENEMIES ARE MORE AGGRESSIVE AND
TO GIVE ADDITIONAL MONEY TO
VLADAMIR PUTIN IS REALLY IN THE
LONG-TERM DETRIMENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> Trace: YOU TALK ABOUT THE
PERSIAN GULF, WHAT ARE THEY
SAYING ABOUT THE AMERICAN ENERGY
POLICY?
THE PRESIDENT GONE TO OPEC TO
GET MORE OIL ON THE MARKET, WHAT
ARE THEY SAYING?
THEY HAVE BEEN HESITANT TO DO
THAT, WHAT IS THE WORD OVER
THERE?
BELIEF THE UNITED STATES SHOULD
BE DOING MORE TO HELP ITSELF?
>> John: WE OUGHT TO BE DOING
MORE TO HELP OURSELVES, IT IS
INCUMBENT UPON US TO DO THAT.
THERE ARE WAYS WE CAN PROTECT
THE ENVIRONMENT WITHOUT
PUNISHING THE ECONOMY, I DON’T
KNOW DEMOCRATS UNDERSTAND THAT
MAJOR CONCEPT, WHAT I SAW IN THE
PERSIAN GULF WAS MORE AGGRESSIVE
IRAN.
SEEING IT WITH COMMUNIST CHINA,
SEEING WITH VLADAMIR PUTIN AND
NORTH KOREA, TALK ABOUT THE
THINGS WE HAVEN’T DONE IN
CONGRESS, NATIONAL DEFENSE
AUTHORIZATION ACT SHOULD HAVE
BEEN PASSED MONTHS AGO, BEEN ON
THE BACK BURNER FOR JOE BIDEN
AND SCHUMER, NEVER WANT TO SEND
OUR MEN AND WOMEN INTO A FAIR
FIGHT, WE WANT THEM TO HAVE
STRENGTH, PROJECT EQUIPMENT,
HAVE MANPOWER, FIREPOWER THEY
NEED AND THIS ADMINISTRATION IS
WRONG ON ENERGY AND HAVE BEEN
WEAK, THIS PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
WEAK ON NATIONAL DEFENSE.
WHEN HE CAME INTO OFFICE, HIS
FIRST BUDGET SUPER-SIZED
GOVERNMENT ON EVERYTHING, EXCEPT
TWO AREAS WE DIDN’T KEEP UP WITH
INFLATION UONE WAS DEFENSE, THE
OTHER HOMELAND SECURITY, OUR
NATION DESERVES BETTER.
>> Trace: YOU MAKE A GOOD POINT
BECAUSE YOU HAVE RUSSIAN TROOPS
AMASSING AT THE UKRAINIAN
BORDER, CHINA WITH THREATENING
LANGUAGE TOWARD TAIWAN, AND THE
WINDOW IS NARROWING TO GET THIS
DONE.
IT HAS BEEN PASSED 60 YEARS IN A
ROW, THE WINDOW IS NARROWING,
HOW DO YOU GET THIS DONE
QUICKLY?
>> John: YOU’RE RIGHT, THE
WINDOW IS NARROWING BECAUSE WE
HAVE THAT, WE HAVE THE DEBT
CEILING AND JOE BIDEN AND CHUCK
SCHUMER WANT TO PASS MASSIVE TAX
AND SPENDING BILL BY CHRISTMAS.
WE HAVE AN ENTIRE REPUBLICAN
CONFERENCE WHO WANTS TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO DEFEAT IT.
THE BEST CHRISTMAS PRESENT FOR
AMERICANS, BLOCK INCREASED TAXES
AND BLOCK BILLS THAT CAUSES MORE
INFLATION AND THE MORE PEOPLE
KNOW WHAT IS IN THE BILL, THE
WORSE IT BECOMES, PEOPLE DON’T
LIKE MANY THICKS IN THIS BILL,
WHICH WILL RAISE TAXES AND
INCREASE INFLATION.
>> Trace: SENATOR JOHN BARRASSO,
DR. JOHN BARRASSO, THANK YOU FOR